faut-il reporté la rentrée scolaire non
ferme et catégorique de jean michel
blanquer
parce que l'éducation n'est pas une
variable d'ajustement dit il protéger
les élèves et les adultes et assurer
l'éducation pour tous avec la rentrée au
1er septembre
tels sont les deux objectifs de la
rentrée en s'appuyant sur notre
protocole sanitaire
l'éducation n'est pas une variable
d'ajustement elle est essentielle pour
tous nos enfants
certes encore faut-il assurer la
protection des élèves et de leurs
professeurs que prévoit donc le ministre
de l'éducation nationale pour cette
rentrée scolaire fin de la distanciation
physique dans les cours de récréation et
dans les salles de classe accès aux jeux
extérieurs et partage d'objets à nouveau
autorisée pour éviter la propagation du
virus
jean michel blanquer repropose et c'est
très sérieux de faire classe dehors en
plein air vous avez des initiatives qui
sont très bonne actuellement pour faire
classe en plein air parce que le temps
le permet actuellement le permettra
aussi sans doute ans au mois de
septembre
il est une vertu pédagogique à faire
classe en plein air autre mesure de ce
protocole sanitaire mis en place après
concertation avec le ministère de la
santé et le haut conseil de santé
publique
le port du masque obligatoire pour tous
enseignants et élèves de 11 ans et plus
le masque pour les élèves est une
fourniture comme une autre comme on
vient avec sa trousse ou ses cahiers ses
paroles devant le fou rire avec
désormais les masques lavables
évidemment dans les cas les plus les
plus extrêmes on sera capable de fournir
des masques aux enfants si nécessaire le
masque une fourniture comme une autre
comprenez à la charge des parents alors
certes l'allocation de rentrée scolaire
est en hausse de 100 euros cette année
mais c'est loin d'être suffisant pour la
fcpe la fédération de parents d'élèves
estiment que le budget des masques
s'élève à 200 euros par mois pour une
famille avec deux enfants
il est évident qu'en france le masque
doit être pris en charge par la
puissance publique dans les écoles comme
il l'est dans les entreprises par les
employeurs
sinon on organise l'inégalité certaines
collectivités territoriales ont
rapidement réagi
i comme les régions île de france et
occitanie par exemple elles ont annoncé
la distribution de masques en textile à
tous les lycéens les professeurs seront
pour leur part équipé par l'éducation
nationale
et si le port du masque leur est
inconfortable
ils ont la possibilité de le retirer
sous conditions lorsqu'il ya une
distanciation physique de plus de 2 m là
on est dans des sujets aussi de bon sens
il est possible pour le professeur
d'enlever d'enlever son masque c'est
c'est quelque chose qui est en quelque
sorte possible que doit-on comprendre de
ses propos que la distanciation d'au
moins deux mètres et inutile dans la rue
les transports en commun en entreprise
le ministre de la santé n'est pas
d'accord au niveau vielles vers en
appelle d'ailleurs à la plus grande
vigilance notamment de la part des plus
jeunes il ne faut pas que le virus
puisse passer des plus jeunes aux moins
jeunes
c'est ce que nous avons constaté dans
certains pays autour de nous et c'est ce
qui a pu provoquer dans ces pays là une
augmentation sensible de l'épidémie
parents d'élèves professeurs syndicats
et politiques s'inquiètent de ce retour
sur les bancs de l'école le 1er
septembre alors qu'une deuxième vague du
virus plane toujours sur la france et
que le nombre de nouvelles infections
augmente
une séance de rattrapage attend jean
michel blanquer pour sa conférence de
presse du 26 août
l'occasion peut être pour le ministre de
l'éducation de corriger certaines
modalités d'organisation de cette
rentrée scolaire